dee た
[音楽]
いきます
この施設
なんだと思いますか
僕ら土木技術者は地下神殿と呼んでます
しかしんで見た感じねへっ
a 棟
福岡市博多区のさんの声の地下にあります
ちょっと前に博多駅の地下に豪雨によって水がドバーっと流れ込みました
死者もでました
そんな悲劇を二度と繰り返さない
そんな思いで
福岡市が作った施設です
この
地下神殿のある公園
その横に実はや救助もあるんです
野球場も
道路や歩道の高さから掘り下げてできています
わかりますかね
雨が降って山へ
街が浸水すると思ったらドバーッと水を引き込むんです
そうすると街の水位が下がってみんなが守られる
そういう施設なんです
実はこの施設
もうすでに4回も皆の命を守っているんです
してました
4回を守っているのになかなかみんなこの事実
知らないんです
一昨年熊本地震が起こりました
去年は
ほっ9章9分豪雨で水害が起こりました
強烈な油冷
土砂が迫ってくる水が迫ってくる街が一気に消えされます
現地で僕は無力感に駆られました
テレビや報道では
消防とか自衛隊の方が人命救助活動を頑張っている姿がよく報じられます
でも
彼らはどうやってその現地に入れるんでしょうか
実は地元の土木品車
自分も被災し家族も命が危うい
それでもみんなのために真っ先に現地に駆けつけ
人命救助の道を開き二次災害を防止するための活動をやり続けるんです
私も土木技術者の端くれ家族には災害が起こったときは
側にはいれねーよと
伝えています
私自身小学校4年生の時に長崎大水害に遭いました
命からがら救出されました
その後
僕の暮らしを戻してくれたのは土木技術者の方々
その人たちは
すごい重機を去っそうだ奴って
めちゃめちゃカッコよかったんです
それで僕はどう北技術者になりました
ベトナムに行ってきました
ベトナム人や車がバンバン往来する橋の下柱はこんなです
かなみも錆びててこのかなみがもし切れたら箸が倒壊します
でも普通にとってんです日本なら間違いなく通行止めです
カンボジアに行ってきました
アスファルトやコンクリートで舗装がままならない
車が通るとブワーッと埃だらけです
公共事業
もともと
まあ大名さん通過お殿様つが
太田3たちをと
公であるみんなの
暮らしを守るために
彼は落ち推奨生徒みんなでやろうぜともにやろうぜとやってきた事業が公共事業だった
はずなんです
なのに今
一部の公務員は公務員と土木業界が
この両者がともに行っている事業俺は関係ないと思われちゃってるんです
in フラワー
みなさんの生活レベルや文化のレベルを打つ数
鏡なんです公共事業なんです
他人ごとではないんです
ちょっと100年という時間を感じてみましょう
これ100年前の福岡の地図です
赤いとこ海岸線ですね
その500年今の福岡の
地形です
100年前の海岸線はあの昭和通りのちょっと向こうぐらい
100年間という時間はこれほど
インフラを劇的に変化させるんです
日本の高度成長期戦後70年
あまりで
皆さんの
便利屋当たり前の暮らしはここまで進化しているんです
沖縄で倒壊したはずです
倒壊した時道路自体は通行止め
されていました
でも
倒壊したんです
もしも下に人がいたらと思うと
ゾッとしますよね
こんなことが起こらないために
これからインフラのメンテナンスはとても大切なんです
例えばちょっと足をかけ変えましょう
橋が今はりましたその隣に仮の橋を架けて皆さんが支障なく通れるようにして
そして橋を撤去して橋を新しく作るで出来上がったら
通りにくい道をまた元に戻してそして仮の橋を撤去する
こうやって
端を作り変えていると新しく作るのの最初からねゼロから作るのの良い2倍から3倍
バンバンお金かかるわけです
でももしも皆さんが
この橋は皆の者だと
まあしゃあないよ治す間はちょっと俺回り道するよと言っていただけたならその場で
撤去して新設する
作り変えるのは1.5倍ぐらいのコストでできるかもしれません
こんな風に
これまでお話ししてきたように
日本の
土木技術者ま毒勇者は
安全を守って
経済発展を進めてきました
なのに
今悩み事
土木技術者になり卓球若者がいないんです
土木技術者人口はピーク時の4分の3です
今
25%減っちゃった
こんな土木技術者たちが
お医者さんになりたいとか
例えば弁護士になりたいプロ野球選手になりたい
そんな風に俺は土木技術者になりたいっていう風に言ってもらいたいんです
なのになかなかこの価値や意義が伝わらない
なんかね悪い話ばかりが報道されちゃうんです
確かに
談合とか
癒着とか
ありましたありましたよ
でもねぇ
いわしてください一部の人がやったことなんですほとんどの土木技術者は
胸に誇りを持って
俺達がやるんだと使命感を持って働いているんです
仮に不可能なことがあるなら
こうやって生身でぶら下がってでも端を点検する守る
不可能を可能にすることに挑戦し続けているわけです
それなのに土木業界なかなか伝わらない
ここに2つの理由があると思っています
まずは一つ目
そもそものビジネスの構造としてなかなか
皆さんに
伝わりにくい構造であるということです
自動車業界は
皆さん市民の方がユーザーですだからメーカーだってディーラーだって俺のところの
ハイブリッド自動車すげーだろ
こんな凄い技術を持ってんだということを伝えるんです
でも
土木業界
皆さんはサービスを受ける対価として納税します
その税金を持って
管理者公務員の方々とかがお仕事を民間企業に発注するわけです
出すわけですねそうすると民間企業は何をするかというと国土交通省とか
福岡県とか福岡市に行ってハイハイハイハイとうちはこんなスゲー技術を持っています
で
言うんですめちゃめちゃ言うんですでも
皆さんは置いてけぼりです
すごい技術もすっごい気もすっごい魅力もなかなか伝わらないんです
二つ目
二つ目はねぇ
良いニュースがつまんないということです
例えば例えば都市高速
投資高速を昨夜ね点検しました
めちゃめちゃ点検して悪い所ちょい直しました
だから今日も当たり前に都市高速が支えています
今日いらっしゃる方は暖かいでもニュースソースにはならないですよね
ニュースでこれを言われることはないでしょう
そうだから悪いニュースばかりが報じられて
良いニュースがボンド出ることもなく
なーんとなく悪循環を繰り返すんです我々土木技術者も大マスコミに報道でたたかれる
とビビってしまって何も言わなくなるんです
また叩かれるんちゃうかと思うんです
だからこれから
私は公共事業は
公が共に響きあう公共事業じゃないといけないと思うんです
みんなで子や孫の世代の未来を創るためにみんなで考えてみんなで協力してやっていく
んです
これが僕が目指す公共事業です
そのために私は
土木技術者の有志たちとともに
この価値や魅力を伝えていこうという活動を始めました
子どもたちに土木技術に触れてもらうイベントとか
市民の方々と土木技術者が直接触れ合って語り合う場所を設けたりしています
さらに全国でも同じような取り組みも取り組みをする
土木技術者たちがどんどん出てきております
もし本日私の話を聞いて
やるじゃんと僕かっこいいじゃんと思っていただけたなら
ぜひアンテナを高くしていただきまして我々のイベントをチェックして
全国のイベントをチェックして
そして
是非参加して土木技術者とコミュニケーションしてください
皆さんが理解してくれたら人は
理解したらきっと正しさの判断は変わると僕は信じています
土木は
人気の商売になります
ありがとうございさん
[拍手]